déjenme dibujar un conocido diagrama pv
okay este es mi eje del volumen el de
abajo el vertical es el de presión ok
este es el de presión y este es el de
volumen y les mostré hace bastantes
vídeos ya que si empezamos en cierto
estado aquí en el diagrama tv justo aquí
y vamos cambiando la presión y el
volumen para obtener otro estado y lo
hacemos de forma cuasi estática
esencialmente vamos a estar siempre
cerca del equilibrio así que mis
variables de estado siempre están
definidas podría pintar una trayectoria
justo aquí ok esta es mi trayectoria y
entonces vamos de un estado inicial a
otro final y dijimos bueno si si si
hacemos esto el trabajo realizado por el
sistema es el área debajo de esta curva
y cuando nos movemos de regreso al
estado previo podríamos hacerlo a lo
largo de otra trayectoria más rara este
ok por ejemplo está el trabajo realizado
por el sistema por el sistema sería el
área debajo de esta curva azul y está
que como esta en sentido contrario es
negativa por lo tanto el trabajo neto
realizado es el área
de esta curva déjenme pintarlo de este
color aunque el trabajo neto realizado
por él por el sistema es el área dentro
de este ciclo ok si vamos en estadios en
este sentido de las manecillas del reloj
así que el trabajo neto hecho o
realizado por el sistema es esta área
ahora también sabemos que en cierto
punto sí o sí estamos en algún punto de
este diagrama bebé ok
ese es nuestro estado y justo como
anteriormente si nos vamos a lo largo de
todo este ciclo ok
nuestro nuestras variables de estado no
cambian no cambian y la presión y el
volumen porque estamos en el mismo punto
del diagrama pp pero también nuestra
energía interna como está en el mismo
punto no cambia así que nuestro cambio
en la energía interna
no hay tal cambio ok por qué volvemos al
mismo punto así que nuestro cambio es
simplemente cero el cambio en energía
interna y sabemos que el cambio la
energía interna estaba definido como
esto viene de la primera ley de la
termodinámica viene como el calor
agregado al sistema menos el trabajo
realizado por el sistema
ahora sí vamos a lo largo de este ciclo
en el diagrama pp cuál es nuestro cambio
en la energía interna pues como volvemos
al punto inicial esto es cero ok porque
seguimos en el mismo estado es igual y
esto es igual al calor aplicado menos el
trabajo o bueno ya hemos hecho este
pequeño ejercicio varias veces quizás ya
es la cuarta o quinta vez que lo hacemos
pero no importa porque concluimos que el
calor va a ser igual al trabajo
realizado por el sistema así que esta
área dentro de la trayectoria ya dijimos
que es el trabajo realizado por el
sistema y si no recuerdas de dónde viene
en realidad era la presión por el
volumen x que pequeños cambios o
incrementos en el volumen verdad ya
hemos hecho bastante estas cosas así que
si tenemos cualquier área cierto calor
agregado al sistema o vamos a tener un
calor neto agregado al sistema ok por
ejemplo un calor neto y usamos este
argumento para decir porque el calor no
puede ser una variable de estado no es
una buena variable estado porque de
hecho tuvimos un vídeo completo de esto
si definimos por ejemplo una variable de
estado digamos el calor contenido ok
vamos a definir esta variable de estado
y digamos que el cambio en el calor
contenido por supuesto es igual al
cambio en el calor si estoy agregando
calor al sistema este con este contenido
debería subir el problema con el calor
contenido es que digamos que estamos por
aquí ok que estamos en este estado ok
que el calor contenido es igual a 12 5
aunque ahora ya les mostré que si nos
vamos a lo largo de esta trayectoria
vamos y venimos hay cierta área
contenida en esta trayectoria verdad en
esta en este ciclo al cual le agregamos
calor así que esta área justo de aquí ok
por ejemplo es q es igual a w que es el
área y es igual a 2 entonces cada vez
que recorramos este ciclo por ejemplo
empezamos en 5 recorremos este ciclo y
cuando volvemos ya tenemos un calor de 7
y luego si vamos otra vez ya tendremos
calor de 9 y podríamos tener este
muchísimos incrementos cada vez que
recorremos este este este ciclo así que
con el calor contenido no puede ser una
buena variable de estado depende del
como recorremos este ciclo verdad así
que para tener una variable de estado
necesitamos que el cambio sea cero por
ejemplo la energía interna la energía
interna si empezamos con 10 al ir a lo
largo de este ciclo vamos a tener que
terminamos con la misma cantidad de
energía interna así que por ejemplo
también la entropía la entropía podemos
hacer muchísimas cosas locas el punto es
que cuando volvemos al mismo estado
tenemos la misma cantidad por ejemplo la
presión si fuera cinco atmósferas bueno
al regresar vamos a tener las mismas
cinco atmósferas verdad ok no depende de
la trayectoria en la que nos movimos si
estamos en cierto estado ahora el calor
contenido no funciona no funciona ya lo
vimos en algunos vídeos este por ejemplo
ahí definimos la entropía que a lo mejor
nos relacionaba un poquito lo que era el
calor pero bueno supongamos que queremos
hacer una variable de estado que al
mismo tiempo me mide el calor obviamente
vamos a tener que hacer algunas cuentas
más finas no podemos simplemente
definirlo como el calor contenido porque
se va a cambiar no es una variable de
estado válida
así que vamos a ver si podemos crear
alguna sólo vamos a hacer una definición
déjenme llamar a esta nueva cosa que voy
a que más o menos va a ser como el calor
ok vamos pero vamos a llamarlo a esto
entalpía
y vamos solo a definirlo vamos a jugar
un poquito con esta definición vamos a
definirlo como la energía interna más la
presión por el volumen presión por
volumen
así que cuál sería mi cambio en la en
tal día cuál sería el cambio la entalpía
ok esto sería simplemente el cambio de
estas dos cosas el cambio en la energía
interna más el cambio de la presión por
el volumen
más el cambio de la presión por el
volumen ahora esto es interesante y
quiero dejar un punto aquí esto por
definición es una variable de estado
válida porque es sólo la suma de otras
variables de estado verdad en cualquier
punto del diagrama pd y esto es cierto
también si hiciera cosas como por
ejemplo la entropía o la temperatura que
son también variables de estado
en cualquier momento en cualquier punto
o simplemente va a ser una variable de
estado la presión también y el volumen
también así que si sumamos estas dos
cosas es una variable de estado válida
porque solo es la suma de un buen de
otras variables de estado muy bien así
que veamos si podemos de alguna forma
relacionar esto con lo que ya hemos
establecido acerca de las variables de
estado de ahora en adelante vamos a
trabajar esta definición porque funciona
como la suma de variables de estado
diferentes así que veamos cómo
relacionar esto con el calor así que
sabemos que del tau del tau ok si
estamos trabajando con la energía
interna o el cambio en la energía
interna no estoy hablando de otras cosas
simplemente va a ser igual al calor
aplicado calor aplicado al sistema menos
el trabajo realizado por el sistema
verdad déjenme poner todo esto además el
camión lenta al pia es igual al calor
menos el trabajo eso es solo el cambio
la energía interna más
pepe esto solo es de la definición de la
entalpía ahora esto empieza a parecer
interesante porque quien es el trabajo
realizado por el sistema cual es el
trabajo hecho por el sistema así que
podría escribir como el cambio en la
entalpía es igual al calor aplicado que
menos el trabajo realizado por el
sistema y si tengo un sistema aquí
digamos aquí con el pistón y ya sabes
estamos haciendo un proceso cuasi
estático con los granitos clásicos todo
lo que hemos hecho en estos vídeos
cuando aplicamos calor o digamos que
vamos removiendo algunos de estos
granitos este vamos a estar en un
distinto equilibrio pero que estar
realmente ocurriendo lo que tenemos es
cierta presión que está aplicándose aquí
arriba y este pistón va a subir y el
volumen va a incrementarse y hemos visto
en múltiples vídeos que el trabajo
realizado por el sistema de esta forma
lo puedes ver como el volumen
el volumen o más bien por la presión por
el cambio en el volumen por el cambio en
el volumen y vamos a agregar esta otra
parte ok así que esto fue nuestro cambio
en la energía interna ok y sumamos el
cambio de pepe definido de esta forma
ahora algo interesante algo interesante
que está ocurriendo aquí es que dijimos
que queríamos definir algo porque
queríamos medir más o menos el calor
contenido así que el cambio en la
entropía debería ser igual al calor si
queremos que eso ocurra estos dos
términos de acá deben cancelarse y de
alguna forma necesitamos que estos dos
sean iguales para que nuestro cambio en
la cntc al pie solo sea el calor así que
estos dos términos deben ser iguales
bajo qué condiciones esto es cierto
cuando son iguales estos dos términos
otra forma de verlo es bajo qué
condiciones el cambio en la presión por
el volumen es igual a la presión por el
cambio en el volumen cuando esto ocurre
cuando puedo hacer que este a que esta
afirmación sea válida porque queremos
que éstos sean iguales para qué
al igual al calor agregado bueno la
única forma en que podemos hacer que
esta afirmación sea cierta es si la
presión es constante ok
presión constante presión constante
ahora porque es esto pensémoslo
matemáticamente si esta es una constante
cuando hago una constante por el cambio
de una variable por ejemplo si fuera 55
veces el cambio de algo es el cambio de
5 veces que sea algo verdad
matemáticamente funciona o si lo ves
desde el otro punto de vista si esta es
una constante puedes sacarlo como factor
verdad por ejemplo si si digamos que
queremos ver el cambio de 5 x donde x es
alguna unidad qué sé yo y eso sería
simplemente 5x final menos 5x inicial y
podrías factorizar el 5 verdad esto es 5
por equis final menos equis inicial y
eso simplemente 5 por el cambio en x es
casi muy obvio para explicar a veces
cuando uno sobre explica las cosas puede
parecer confuso pero bueno esto aplica
ok el 5 puede ser la analogía de una
constante que en este caso sería la
presión para que esta ecuación sea
cierta así que
la presión es constante esto es una
suposición clave para esto ok entonces
el calor que está siendo aplicado en
abajo o presión constante podríamos
escribirlo de esta forma okay porque
esto es clave la presión constante
entonces nuestra definición bajo la
hipótesis de que la presión es constante
nuestra definición que hicimos del
entalpía de fin definida como el cambio
la energía interna más presión por el
volumen es una en este tipo de sistemas
nos da que el cambio lenta el pia es
igual a simplemente el calor aplicado al
sistema estas dos cosas serían iguales y
por lo tanto se cancelan y solo nos
queda el calor ok esto solo es válido
cuando la presión es constante así que
qué es lo que ocurrió aquí en nuestro
diagrama pp que está ocurriendo cuando
cuando la presión es constante déjenme
dibujar el diagrama pv
ok
entonces
ok ahí está p este es b así que qué está
ocurriendo con compresión constante
estamos a una presión fija y si estamos
de esa forma sólo nos movemos a lo largo
de esta línea podríamos ir de este
estado a este otro o no sé y poder ir y
regresar no importa ok
nosotros no sabemos cómo nos movemos
puede ser de muchas formas pero cuál es
el área debajo de esta curva no hay
curvas realmente verdad así que vemos
como apachurrado este diagrama más bien
cuál es el área dentro del ciclo en este
caso no hay ciclo ok debido a esto no
tienes no tienes ese problema de estado
verdad porque no hay no hay calor neto
que está siendo agregado al sistema
cuando vas de este punto a cualquier
otro verdad y regresas así que debido a
esto puedes ver esto visualmente como
que le entalpía en una presión constante
se está moviendo el volumen hacia arriba
y hacia abajo pero en realidad
esta es una gran suposición verdad que
la presión sea constante esto nos sirve
por ejemplo con reacciones químicas
especialmente con aquellas que ocurren
en un vaso de precipitados oa nivel del
mar o quién sabe no pero que ocurren a
una presión constante ya sabes si estoy
sentado en la playa y con mi juego de
química y tengo un vaso de precipitados
o algo y estoy aventando cosas ahí
adentro y estoy viendo alguna reacción o
algo y esto es una presión constante
digamos que estamos a una a una
atmósfera esto es un concepto muy útil
en en el día a día para por ejemplo
todas las expresiones químicas podría no
ser útil para las máquinas porque
estamos cambiando siempre la presión
pero es útil para la química de hecho
cuando estamos trabajando con con hugo
que es lo que va a pasar con la reacción
a presión constante así que lo que vamos
a ver es que está en calp ya la puedes
ver de alguna forma como el calor
contenido cuando la presión es constante
de hecho es el calor contenido cuando la
presión es constante así que de alguna
forma
hemos hemos sido capaces de dar esta
definición que nos sirve para calcular
el calor contenido bajo esta gran
suposición de que la presión es
constante de repente todo se reduce al
calor contenido del sistema ok
así que vamos a hablar un poco más de la
medida del entalpía en bueno después y
vamos a utilizar esto que es bastante
útil cuando tenemos presión constante
ahí la entropía se puede imaginar como
el calor contenido y es útil para
entender las reacciones químicas y el
calor relacionado con es con ellas nos
vemos